you know the biggest do you know the
biggest sporting most viewed sporting
event in the world do you know what's
the most viewed the World Cup it's
crooked I want to say India against
Pakistan 225 million people watched it
oh wow the entire country yeah they're
watching the whole thing yeah I mean
you're talking about 225 million people
this how many people watch the Super
Bowl 104 million so it's running laps
around the Super Bowl oh and by the way
believe it or not the one right now that
they're saying is gonna kill everybody
is the Esports the video game the video
gamers are are lapping Super Bowl right
now they're saying egame Championship is
going to be the most viewed sporting
event in the world matter of fact if it
isn't already and what video games video
games that's not a sport they call it
Esports though that's what they call it
a lot of people
18 year old nerds coming after I know
it's like but you know when you do the
darts and you see them drinking beer and
I go
it is
so so I wanted to get your uh your uh
are you are you pulling up to see if it
actually is time go go to the most
viewed one most what Esports going
number one go number one go number one I
just can't see bass watching this look
at that
5.41 million but it's coming up but if
you go to the most viewed sporting event
of all time okay type in most viewed
most viewed sporting event of all time
the Beijing Olympics uh what does it say
4.7 billion
4.7 billion people watching it holy [ __ ]
that's a lot that's a lot that's a lot
damn it's more than half of the world
dude that's more than half of the world
yeah that seems to be like collectively
the Olympics that's like over a month
period how many people watch but are you
talking about just one specific event
like Super Bowl I'm looking at it right
now Kentucky Derby is there Daytona 500
is there NBA Finals the one in 1998 when
Michael Jordan is uh eight spots 15
spots let's see what we got here
actually I'm curious right now March
Madness 1975 35 million people X Games
37 million people uh let's see a World
Series 1978 44 million people
uh I want to see who number one is here
because I want to say it was cricket 225
million what's this one here rugby
1995 they had a bunch 88 what 800 and
there's no way 800
857 million people watch Dad
rugby holy [ __ ] Asian Games was 986.
uh and then you have UFC there's no way
1.1 billion broadcasts reach
is what they're saying for one of
Connor's fights boxing two billion
people watch Ali Leon Spinks in 78. damn
that's a big number right there
Winter Olympics we got 2.1 billion in 06
what is the most one Cricket there you
go 2.2 billion people wow for 2019
if I watched that
and then we have Tour de France three
and a half billion Tour de France
no it's like a high number FIFA World
Cup 2018
uh 3.57 billion and a most viewed one
was somewhere Olympics 3.6 billion
that's the one you pulled out that one
right there it's pretty sick to see that
so with all the craziness taking place I
believe future looks bright if you
believe future looks bright get your
latest Future looks bright hat of
valuetainment it says future looks
bright here future looks bright here we
got them in white we got them in Black
we got them in red or black on black
sold out these are about to sell out if
you haven't ordered one yet we had a
person in Michigan but one then he
bought three then when those three
people weren't in the office they had to
order 58 of them because people wanted
the future looks bright hat especially
during times like this because ain't
nobody's saying future looks spread
toward your future looks bright hat
click over here and to watch the entire
podcast click here take care everybody
foreign
[Music]